i've ran for myself for a long time i've
hated myself for a long time and
i'm
gay oh i felt like a
million trillion pounds were lifted off
my shoulders it was a secret that i
guarded and protected and lied for for
so many years to be able to just finally
shed all of that and start sort of
peeling off these layers of protection
and armor that i put up was a feeling
that i'm still experiencing you know i
had been through it as far as you know
the media sort of telling my story for
me for so many you know so many years i
just had to remind myself of that show
myself grace and patience and
love and surround myself i had a great
support system with my friends and my
family too coming out colton really
helped me to understand your journey
more
um
i didn't want to be gay and the main
voices in my head were just telling me
you'll get through this you'll get
through this
did doing that series
almost feel like a bit of therapy for
you in a way
it for sure was i thought it was really
important for people to understand
exactly what i was going through we need
to celebrate your engagement
congratulations
how did you know jordan was the one it
wasn't forced it was unexpected and
i mean just like the feeling that you
know i had and he had it just was
undeniable what would you say jordan has
brought into your life other than love
that maybe you didn't have before i just
say balance i mean finding balance both
in in professional life and personal
life and also just someone to to have a
good time with and then i can be as
authentic and as true to myself as i
could be